It's a minute to go here today
ban
nn
ben
1 minute
I'd like to talk about language study again today,
so the theme is that today or we
are changing without knowing it  More and more
famous geisha rut philosophers are coming down and it's like Sua's goodness.
You can't put your feet in the same river,
so even if you don't feel it's always
changing. We and the city are improving.
Well, that's the theme. If you're
interested in my video, please sign up.
Just click on it and I
'll send you the news.
And please hit me gloomy.
Song with me.  Let's study the language It's
sex today in Vancouver The weather isn't good and it's
raining so much that I can't protect it, so I'm
trying to study Arabic and intensively for 3 hours with
that love pearl  Those lessons are
mostly
ponticus angela podcasts or scrubbing and reading with that enemy,
but today my static stats are yeah certainly
good new
that  The number of words I'm doing has increased by 169.
As a result, I've saved or maintained the new words. The link was created
by the wind 200
a. So
I read more than 1800 words of Margo.
That's why I was active today, but that's
40% of the time I was sitting, and I felt the movement while studying.
There is a feeling that there is no such thing. I didn't feel that I was studying the new language when the Arabic numbers were a lifetime
. Basically, my habit of being at the same level.  It's
kind of like that, but it's not really the case.
Actually, as this statistic tells me, I was
able to study a new word and read a lot of
that word, so no money changed.
So, as the philosopher of the geisha said, it's a thousand and hundreds of years ago, but
it's always in the sense that you can't step into the same river again.  Change
Transforms Transforms There are changes, so
even for 9 Arabic
I don't feel like I've made a lot of progress in today's 3 hours, but
compared to the pottery that started, it's just how Arabic is.  I couldn't read Arabic letters, and I made
a
little progress in school little by little.
As a result, that
pondy class now. If you listen to angelo's podcast, you
can understand a lot of words. There are not so many words I don't know.
So, in reality, I don't feel the death of the accident on the day when there was progress
.
It's a machine that you can do, so you have to do it. Your
brain will definitely study, but it's slow and slow, so we don't know
about it
.  I mean, you remember, it
's always there, so there's always that change,
so when you're studying
, don't think that you can't do anything about it and you're not making any progress.
I'm sure I'll make progress And the other is that I think it's better to study intensively for 3 hours like I do
today.
[Music] It
's boring or difficult,
but it's even better if you do it for 3 hours. I
think it's even more effective if you study, but basically you can continue studying.
If it changes, it's inland with the same leather.
Well then, goodbye to that point today dan
Yeah
5 minutes